The Joe Rogan Experience I get
occasionally called by somebody from
inside
and
what I think they're doing
first of all one we may be faking a UFO
situation for reasons that I don't
understand if we are faking a UFO
situation do you think that there's
technology that's available to people in
the United States that is beyond our
current understanding of what's possible
ninety percent no ninety percent now
because it's very hard it's very hard to
imagine physicists continuing to work on
nothing
for their entire careers the number of
people who are going to be retiring
shortly having never actually done
physics as a physicist
we're talking about wasted lives people
are going to be very weird when they
realize that they blew their entire
career
and I believe I can say what many of
these problems are if you want to
humiliate me at a leading University
just ask me to talk you can put it on
video
you don't realize how many things the
standard model has subtly wrong when we
explain it to people it's not that the
lagrangian is wrong not that the rules
are wrong but we say wrong stuff we say
like there are three generations that
are only of matter that are only
distinguished by mass in other words
there's three copies of the stuff here
this is like the wood version and then
there's the plastic version and then
there's the metal version
there aren't three there are two
generations plus an extra imposter
generation which looks like a generation
I mean I can get into these things and
that should be a provocation somebody
says let's call this guy up have him out
and find figure out what he's talking
about doesn't matter
I don't think we're doing physics what
do you think they're doing I think we
are playing paintball rather than going
to war and we're giving prizes for
generals who've command the command the
best paintball Army and then we're
referencing everyone else who's actually
trying to figure out how to fight
to well have you submitted to the
paintball competition
it's like no I don't want to do
paintball I understand that it keeps
your skills up I understand that some of
them are transferable
but I I mean like you've been in street
fights
not since I was a teenagers yeah well I
understand like I haven't been for a
long time
it's it's different than what you guys
do in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu there's lots
of stuff you're not allowed to do yeah
right you're getting a street fight it's
a completely different thing sure
um what we're doing is not physics in
the same sense
so what they're doing is they're we're
doing safe stuff yeah exactly they're
exercising and and the exercises are
keeping people limber they're keeping
people in a fighting mentality it's not
it's not that Brazilian Jiu Jitsu has
nothing to do with fighting we've seen
people use it in the street for sure
right
but small joint manipulation is part of
Street Fighting eye gouging is part of
street fight pulling a knife is part of
street fighting these things are not
part of any reputable gym that you might
go to
I want to do
the thing that isn't paintball
and I didn't want to do it up until
recently because the danger of
unleashing a neutrino a neutron in the
world
is so high now I realize I'm done with
that you guys are willing to play
footsies with Putin you're not going to
survive you're not the responsible
adults I thought you were like if if I
unleash a neutron and it leads to some
sort of proliferation of deadly
technology it's on you it's not on me
you're already taking risks that you
shouldn't be taking
so
if
you would think 90 sure that this is not
coming from here you believe this
because you don't think that the proper
science in order to achieve these kind
of results is being done by the people
that you believe are capable of doing it
that is correct I know that for example
when I talk to Nema
um or when I talked to Juan maldistena
or when I've talked to Natty cyberg
these people are absolutely brilliant
and they don't know the answer unless
they're the greatest actors I've ever
seen so the most brilliant physicists
are looking at these
supposed videos what is the best thing
that's the UFO stuff what are you
talking about man they're not talking
about things that can extend Einstein
right they're my therefore to get back
to your technology question might have
engineering applications because it's
the engineering applications that are
terrifying right right the discovery of
the neutron was one thing the teller
ulam design was its weaponization
so suddenly you know
you can do the Tsar bomb or or Castle
Bravo these unbelievable explosions
which
like the difference between
there are several there were Civil War
veterans who saw action in The Civil War
who lived to see
Ivy Mike in the Pacific
so the Civil War was almost a
thermonuclear war in terms of human
scale it's not it's less than 100 years
different
people have forgotten how terrifying
important wonderful
jaw-dropping and awesome physics is
because it hasn't done anything that
completely screws your mind
like Hiroshima or Nagasaki or Castle
Bravo
with Castle Bravo that was the test in
the Pacific where we thought it was
going to be like controlled in like or
or it was starfish we did an atmospheric
explosion over Hawaii and then the
Russians like hold my beer
yeah you know we remember I'm that guy
five years ago who was saying we need
above ground nuclear tests because all
you people have lost your fear like yes
Eric is crazy but he's correct what's
this one
that's Castle brother oh my God
right like so they detonated in that
facility and they expected it to be far
smaller than it was you know they
detonated in the Pacific right
but it's right next to that facility
that was in the video Yeah would that
was that the facility that was initially
filmed like what
yeah what is this facility that's it was
it you know what I forget atoll
so like we just crazy how long ago that
was and how close it was to the Civil
War if you really put it in that context
well that this is what I'm trying to say
is
what I'm trying to tell you look at that
you
that's so insane have you done this in
Oculus no I have not I highly recommend
if they're not going to let us do a nuke
above ground so that we can save
ourselves by fear
all right this is really this is
religious stuff yeah it is religious
like we are we we have announced if
somebody is listening to these tests
that we did
my belief is very shortly before you get
the ability to Traverse the cosmos if
that is possible if that is possible
you let off in Nuke
right it's like yeah it's like you know
you've had kids there's some stuff that
happens right before they figure out how
to break out of the crib you know that's
part of UFO focusing too fat man a
little boy that's a big part of UFO that
once they drop those that's when all the
UFOs started appearing
so the question is is
you know
the analogy I give so I talked to Avi
about the following thing I am a fan of
something I call the doubly scientific
method
the usual scientific method makes a
hidden assumption that it never voices
which is if we're going to study orcas
we assume that we are smarter than orcas
or if we're going to study cephalopods
right
like an octopus we think we're smarter
and what do we do we disguise ourselves
we create artificial environments we do
all sorts of crazy things based on the
fact that we're smarter than what we
study from everything from rocks to
orcas
the doubly scientific method says okay
assume that you're studying a rat in a
maze but you yourself are the rat in
somebody else's maze now you have to
look up the intelligence scale not just
down
and in the doubly scientific method you
have to assume that whatever is studying
you is hiding from you the way you are
hiding from your subjects so if you see
somebody in a Duck Blind for example and
he's studying ducks
you understand that somebody may be
hiding from you they might be able to
use multiple dimensions of time they
might be able to cloak themselves and
disguise themselves or for example if
you take microscopic UFOs
um
this GLA this cup has a radius of R and
a circumference of 2 pi r
disc that it spans is pi r squared in
area but if you look at this cup it's
much larger than pi r squared because we
pushed it out you could have a sphere
where if you could cheaply engineer
space time not through the Einstein
field equations but through the
successor theory that recovers Einstein
you could have an entire stadium inside
of a tennis ball
just the way this cup doesn't blow your
mind until you realize that its area is
much greater than pi r squared
you could why look for a Giant floating
thing in the sky if you could Bend space
and time and you could play with the
rulers the way I'm saying
I would put this in a tiny little
profile
whoa
so we're only looking at it in terms of
our understanding of the distance
between objects planets gravity we're
looking at that all that stuff where if
it didn't exist if somehow or another we
lived in some contained environment we
had no concept of space whatsoever and
then we gained access to it we would be
unbelievably overwhelmed if you lived in
some sort of underground facility your
entire life I love this and then one day
you got a chance to go outside and see
the Keck observatory in in Hawaii right
in a clear night with no moon you would
you would be overwhelmed you wouldn't be
able to believe that the world was as
big as it really was or that the
Universe was as big as it was yeah it's
an impedance mismatch if you watch
meteor showers the way my family does
um
uh
it's it's religious it's it's TR it's
transformational it's transcendent
the problem as you know from the default
uh default mode Network right is that
mostly what your brain is doing is not
communicating information but screening
right your eyes your fovea is precious
because that's the thing that can
resolve at very high levels but like I
can barely see Jamie out of the corner
of my eye because my peripheral vision
can't be at the same level as my phobia
I'd be overwhelmed right
so we're talking about tapping in to a
picture of the world that we are not our
brain is not prepared for the idea the
time is multi-dimensional that was the
whole point of giving Lex another watch
we don't have a way to think about I'll
meet you at 5 15 and 12 30.
according to two different scales of
time
or for example time and space if I'm
correct the 14-dimensional manifold that
has all the quantum going on on it is
split probably seven and seven
dimensions because we have six extra
time dimensions and four extra space at
add six to one and three to four and you
get seven
so space and time are
interchangeable there's a duality
between them all of this stuff
is like you know okay it's how you hit
on chicks in a bar hey let me tell you
something about space and time you never
thought about oh my God does that work
what worked for me
that's why I'm not in better shape so
do you think now when you were talking
about these people that want that keep
Mañana in you and not giving you access
to whatever they're talking about do you
think they're talking about some sort of
an engineering solution to this type of
technology I argument anyone in Striking
Distance
in three years so how could they have
something that you don't that's going to
change your way of looking is it
possible that you've missed something I
can just be wrong
first of all
like this is my this is my life's work
what's the way they phrase it to you
which part the part about it changing
the way you see the world
Eric you know like I'll complain about
data and like that's not the data we
have what we've been showing the public
is down sampled meaning it's it's
fuzzier it's low resolution
um like how clear is it as clear as you
want how clear are you that there's
something to see you can see it with
your own eyes
there's no question see if I was you
know I just shut the [__] up let them
show me I'd be like let's go I'm not
under any NDA I know but I'm saying I
but you want to know yeah but I want to
know in a different look my life's work
is a is a theory it's one Theory my
entire life is really about one Theory
okay like I do this entertainment thing
and I talk to people and all this stuff
[__] really what I am as an academic
who realize that you can't do academics
inside of the University system and
watch it disintegrate into madness as we
speak I figured this out a long time ago
I want to know whether this is right or
wrong so much better so much more that I
want to know whether UFOs exist UFOs to
me
are an indication of whether I'm right
or wrong
you see it's data it's an input to me
because so if you're right that means
if we have a future it means we can
leave not the planet but the solar
system we can explore the cosmos are
traversable
if we can leave anything else can visit
if you look at the entirety of the
universe and you imagine that ultimately
there are societies that destroy
themselves because they get Atomic
weapons before they figure out how to
leave
some societies are smarter than that and
they'll be able to leave and and
colonize the cosmos and for them not to
be here would be Madness